[Music]
how low can joe go even the dems don't
want to know it's one thing after the
next for the prez who stumbles reading
text
glad i didn't screw that up that would
have been hypocritical
first old joe's being called out for his
official statement on the assassination
of former japanese prime minister shinzo
abi abi somebody help me
abe thank you when he blamed the
assassination on gun violence
way to bury the lead
or the lead
japan has some of the strictest gun laws
in the world but it's that damn gun
violence again at least joe didn't pin
it on white supremacy or trump
they'll give it a week and joe's
handlers will link the whole
assassination to january 6th
yeah
then there's this mess
majority rights and i quote
women it's a quote now from the majority
women are not without electoral or
political power
it is noteworthy that the percentage of
women who registered to vote and cast a
ballot is consistently higher than the
percentage of the men who do so end of
quote repeat the line
women are not without electoral and or
political or maybe precisely not and or
or political power
he really is a hostage reading a ransom
note
but he does it so well i believe him and
apparently the new york times got the
go-ahead to stop covering for this
cognitive cupcake saying quote
he often shuffles when he walks and
aides worry he will trip on a wire
he stumbles over words during public
events and they hold their breath to see
if he makes it to the end without a gaff
well you'd hold your breath too if joe
missed his 10 am changing
meanwhile
he said worst things about you believe
me
meanwhile his approval rating hit a new
all-time low 29 in a new civics poll
that number drops any lower joe might
try to sniff its hair
and as joe's woes grows
thank god for hunter and his newest
video leaked footage of him when what
appears to be crack
i just laid out the bag
it's 2.06
2.07
without the
bag 2.0
he really is the smartest guy joe knows
she was off by .01 of a gram and he used
to scale and he nailed the hooker on it
and it does i have to admit it look like
parmesan cheese so he was right about
that kat uh we got a lot to go over here
and i uh i i don't agree with people
hacking people's phones
especially when the person who's hacked
makes me wish i had a more fun life yeah
he makes me feel boring i know i look i
go like wow i don't do anything anymore
yeah
he's not that young either and he's
going down slides naked and having sex
with russian escorts and having money
wired to and from
yeah i think that having money wired to
and from probably is a bonus that most
of us don't have exactly because i feel
like if that were me i'd be in big
trouble no
you're not you're not the offspring of a
president no if that were me i don't i
don't think i'd be coming back to work
which is a bummer if i was still able to
come to work and be a crackhead i don't
think i could balance the two yeah no
well that's what makes him a great
business that's why i've never smoked
crack because i think i'd love it yeah
[Laughter]
[Applause]
i think we're you guys too
we're really changing the fox audience
yeah
jim
i mean every look every he's every when
we're old we're going to be screwed up i
mean right i'm screwed up now yeah but
we're not president
no i i
no we're not
i would hope the first time i drop a
deuce in my pants and i don't know where
i'm at they wouldn't let me read a
prompter and run a country
that's just me though
[Laughter]
i just know if you ask me to get in a
compact car with him while he's driving
i ain't doing it and that alone should
tell you we got a serious situation yeah
yeah yeah yeah and he's i mean they're
constantly having to remind him rob of
of of like things just basic things
little cards and crap oh and then but
here's what i'm asking the new york
times is now jumping all over it aren't
they doing it i mean they're doing it
because they got the go-ahead they're
going to get rid of them yeah i mean
look that's what all this is about this
is about like making it safe for
somebody to run against him yes but if
you read the article that was really
amazing because he had all the aids and
doing all that other stuff the denial
stuff was like actually you know he's as
sharp as attack he calls us up in the
middle of the night he's like rewriting
speeches and policy papers which is so
stupid because the reason people voted
for him was because he's old they wanted
it calm they wanted no drama
he's not in trouble because he's old
yeah if a young verl incredibly healthy
man also uh stop people from drilling
for oil stop people from building
refineries and uh and
wrote checks to people to increase
inflation they'd be at 29 too this guy's
got a policy problem not an age problem
also daughtering old man would be fine
if he wasn't such a [ __ ] i had a really
great point to make about the fact that
joe was elected because he was older but
he's actually like an empty vessel that
is controlled by young workstars that's
the problem that's the problem yeah so
the policy is not coming from
joe biden it's coming from people within
the white house i think though biden is
really trying to flood the zone with
fakery the grandpa goofery and
buffoonery is kind of an act
he want he doesn't want to do anything
he's like if i if they think that i am
so out of it and i'm shuffling around
here like i'm wearing like like bedroom
shoes i stole from a cheap motel where
cheap motels don't have bedroom shoes
anyway see if they really wanted to
improve his
physical performance they could buy him
some new shoes you know your feet change
when you get old you get fallen arches
but they could prevent some of this i
think that he just wants to be at the
beach he's like i got elected by sitting
at home why can't i yeah trips you're
sending me on trips i'll give you trips
he wants to do a zoom presidency and who
wouldn't wouldn't that be great
you know just hang out in the old
basement i'm excited that i'm not going
to be in any trouble because i said i do
not smoke crack hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else